[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome to bleacher reports pregame
picks the show where you
the fans at home can win cash prizes by
simply predicting the random [ __ ]
that occurs in nba pregames as always
i'm your host pierre and i'm joined
with my co-host drewski and tonight
we're gonna have a jam-packed night for
y'all so y'all
sit back relax see all the money we give
away
and let's see what these prizes and
pre-game picks are
let's get it
pretty game show this is where it's at
man let's get to these
picks my boy let's do it boom i told you
he's showing off the money with this
look yes steph curry
wow i'm usually right welcome to pregame
picks
let's get it
come on my boy man i'm excited to have
you and do this but you know
my famous ass co-host you know what i'm
saying i'm honored to have you here you
got the rollie on could have been
records i see
the boys shining and looking like a bag
of money but ava hey drew
let's get to these picks though man
let's get to these pics
we gotta do it we gotta go though
tonight so
for those that don't know these are the
picks that everybody at home who's
waiting to see if they win have been
putting on the beach report app all day
picking what's going to happen drewski
the first challenge that we do have
is what will james harden rock to the
arena tonight
the second challenge is which clipper
is a specific group of four clippers we
have lou williams
sergey baka paul george or kawhi leonard
which one out of the four will be the
first
out of the tunnel that's gonna be an
interesting one who dunks first in
warm-ups
kevin durant or kawhi leonard and then
last but not least will the final shot
of the nets warm-up be a make or a miss
drewski which one of these four
stands out to you for tonight
uh i think the one that stands out the
most to me is probably the outfit one
for james harden
i always like to see he he he you know
he'd be styling man
i've seen him in uh maybe having like
his little like
plaid flannels on you know a little
button-down
little pla you you got one on right now
actually
hey man come on man i'ma you know me i'm
you know
me and james right next she got the same
stuff you know we got the same stuff but
i'm glad you're saying
the james hard thing you've lost me
you've lost me now
you don't believe me and james hard got
the same [ __ ]
never fans that's in the comments
comment if you think me
and james harden have the same style as
cap or no cap leave a comment
juicy let's get to some of the past
wardrobe styles that we've seen
from before we get to that here are some
of the fans that
are voting for what james harden will
wear we have the hoodie
we got the jacket we got the sweater and
then of course
high fashion this right here is what you
were referring to this is high fashion
am i correct drewski what i'm rocking
no yes or no i wouldn't i wouldn't have
that
fashion oh man i'm getting [ __ ] on by
my own co-host
here go james harden some of his past
outfits drewski talk to me on some of
these this is just a plain jacket
that one this girl is playing james so
my [ __ ] is just whatever but that just
go hard
okay i see where we are okay i see where
we are
i see where we are is that high fashion
or is that feeling that no this high
fashion
right here uh yeah you got to tell me
what high fashion is because apparently
from you i don't know
i usually know yeah i know yeah i i
wouldn't say you would know of course
not
but this right here okay now this is
stop
if this is how this is your style you
see how you throw the
fake hands in the pocket the fake hands
in the pocket right there you like that
that's right you know you know all about
that oh
you know i've actually worn this in a
skit before
yes you know juice steve can we can we
rese
can we recycle this fit one more time
and then
i believe we have on fire the skit in
which you're wearing this
jacket yeah
this [ __ ] is a little different than how
james harden is wearing it
[Laughter]
that's what i was saying that stylist
had sent me a selection and he also sent
james harden a better one
obviously but the bubble jacket no you
can't go wrong with that man
put it put it side by side if we can
okay see yeah i have the same stylus too
though
i have the same stylus tools what i'm
telling you see classic
i'm just
that's all you got to say man that's all
you got to say man come on
hey hey hey hey juicy
what baby say [ __ ] [ __ ] instead of
bitter old
i don't even know if that's what baby
said though hey
quick rip is not what he said you had me
saying it wrong but quick reminder of
some of the people that potentially
will take home two hundred dollars hey
shout out to my boy
aka 96 and the hoodie category drew ski
i'm feeling like the hoodie i'm feeling
like james harden coming real simple
with the hoodie tonight
mm-hmm 200 dollar winner
so i'm rooting for you i'll tell you how
fast i'm rooting for you get this money
you going high fashion now here we go
this is the reveal
just the reveal is this okay is this
high fashion or is
what are we categorizing was this just a
jacket hoodie
we leaning on you cause you know you
gotta know
yeah if you know what fashion is you
know that's high fashion there ain't no
regular plain jane hoodie that is
actually
a carpet carpet material
if you take a good game if you take a
look just take a gander at it take a
gander
i'm taking it the gingerbread it's like
a gingerbread
house you know uh you don't know what
you're getting okay
it's festive it's festive since you
undecided judy
drewski what we're going to do is we're
going to let the people in the comments
let us know
what they think let that
[Music]
let me know if this is high fashion
judy is crazy like i don't know what my
brain was thinking jesus
but drewski i'm mad at you bro i'm not
we
we snipers we for lifers this this ain't
how fast
no pardon thinks it's still christmas
season
this i mean yeah my boy drewski said or
should i say judy said it is a
christmas uh carpet so i would shout out
to reyes
let's see who we deciding yes let's
please decide who it is
i'm still waiting to know if it's high
fashion or we just saying a hoodie
one more time i just want to see him do
a walk through
stevo let's see it one more time for
drewski since he uh he thinks he runs
this damn show like
it ain't my show
i think he's going for 30. he's going
for 30. yeah
so drone roll please we're about to
announce the winners
and the wind is it's a hoodie like i
said so i'm up
one on you that's the hoodie my boy
ak-96 will be taking home 200
along with four other people shout out
to those contestants shout out to
everybody else
that logged on in that bleacher report
app earlier today
and solidified their pick but only five
can take home 200 so congrats to them
if you were one of those five what you
doing with that money bro and be real
don't tell me no [ __ ]
what you doing with you know and get
some merch at jersky2funny.com
so you buying your own merch damn right
could have been records for lifers kyle
rocco university
someone somebody in the comments said
that's high fashion so they agree with
you
um but before we even get into that i'm
still waiting on my
i'm waiting on my boxes of all of that
merch that you got over there could have
been
oh actually i got you i got you we'll
get we'll get you taken care of we'll
get you taken care of
yeah you don't have to worry about that
no more
hey drewski let's take a look at br kit
some of the kicks we had from last week
will be our kick
let's do it oh we got my boy pg
this is actually my favorite player
right here paul george
we got the pg with that five i need some
of those pg if you're watching
let me get a pair please you know nike
just dropped the shoe where you don't
even gotta uh
well you just put your foot in you don't
even got to bend down to put to help you
get in there i saw that drewski i saw
that you hollywood you probably got your
package coming kd13
you see the longhorn edition
katie got some bigfoot right there
kyrie so smooth off the glass kyrie
always got some fire
top five shoe in the game kyrie year and
you're out okay carry seven
which one was your favorite you a cat kd
kyrie paul george
uh i used to like katie's early early on
in katie's shoes
when when i was in high school i liked
his like first ones where you know the
little strap go across the ankle
like the little yes sir yeah you know
what i'm saying those was crazy
but now i'm not gonna lie to you now uh
kyries is like top three for hooper
kicks but pg's up there too though but i
say kyrie over anybody
y'all in the comments let me know if
y'all disagree or agree with drewski
which one was y'all favorites but now
check the credits bleacher report in
association with the nba and the mbpa
are collaborating to turn some of your
favorite teams and players into
hollywood blockbusters
this is a limited merchandise collection
so make sure you go
check out check the credits at
bleacherreportshop.com
shop now again at bleacherreportshop.com
for check the credits
i'm gonna need you to give me some of
that merch too since you run this since
you run this [ __ ] i'm a begging ass guy
i told you that i'm gonna be doing a lot
of begging
yeah you told me you run [ __ ] at this
show i i know
you rush it
you gonna get the newest [ __ ] 100
i appreciate that but we waiting on
challenge two
kawhi paul george lou williams serge
ibaka which one of these four players
will be the first
out of the clipper tunnel we gotta drill
it in i don't want people to think we're
waiting on the actual first player but
which one out of those four
will be the first since you've seen had
all the answers
during rehearsal i'm interested to know
which one of these i'll tell you who a
damn show is
george ibaka who was it
why is it not served that is i don't
even know why it's five people that even
voted that
yeah my man d ward 52 is at home and he
confidently earlier today on bleacher
reports app
picked sergey bacca what's wrong with
that pick
okay and business and the real hooch
it was when y'all made y'all names y'all
knew
yeah i ain't really feeling the real
love so you might be people that
um do your thing it's your show you're
calling the shots you said
okay then ak-96 for me to relax
listen ak 96 has already won 200
that he's back on here uh with a kawhi
leonard pick so if kawhi leonard is
first
that means ak 96 is 400
up by just predictions is that is that
simple everybody at home
that's that here we go juice the first
one out here we go
i'm looking steve i need some closer
shots if possible
i'm trying to see is that is kawhi first
the first pan is on kawhi
if if that's kawaii ak 96
is for no kawaii is the first of the
four
no kawhi is the first of the four drew
it was somebody
else he's the second
he's the second but he's the first of
the four
come on drewski you gotta pay attention
man
y'all cheating so my boy y'all hey ak
ak 96 is up for it first he laughs
if he ain't first he laughs
what type of what type of philosophical
statement is that jessica you never you
ain't never watched talladega nights
nah i'm just joking i'm just joking i
don't want people to get on my ass of
course i've seen ricky bobby but aka
my focus is on ak-96 ak.e6 is 40
i just want the people at home to
understand it is that easy you just get
on that bluetooth report app
for pre-game picks you make your picks
and you could be up 400
ak-96 so salute to ak-96 listen
i want you to tell someone what is up
man
give him some wisdom because i don't
want him to waste that money or do
anything stupid
so waste your money man drop some send
it on whatever you want
waste it don't let it ain't gonna be
here for long don't get down
can't die with it now okay go get
yourself go to the strip club man
and find the first girl you see
ak might be 11 years old that's come on
okay see
all right y'all gonna take me off the
show
hey everybody in the comments give some
wise words to ak96
if i like your comment i will be giving
you a shout out i may give you something
special
i have to get approval from drewski
because he runs the show
yes it's kids bro it's kids somebody is
watching this with their mom and they
just won
well no his if he put 96 that might mean
he was born in 96.
true look at you that boy is intelligent
hey
i want i want to throw something here
while we wait for the next challenge
right so what's up how many
shots do you think kyrie irving can make
in 60 seconds
i want you to tell me that's i want the
people at home to comment
comment how many shots you think kyrie
irving
shots it could be a mid-range a
three-point
it's a as long as he's shooting it i
want everybody in the comments
to let me know immediately flood the
comments with your predictions on how
many shots
kyrie can make in seconds one minute
i don't know i don't know what i'm going
with
i don't know what i'm what you're
thinking i don't know what i'm thinking
because kyrie can get hot but you know
sometimes in these these
you know pregame things they'd be all
cool and nonchalant trying to look sexy
yeah they're trying to be
cool tried to come out the other night
and he just was throwing today
exactly you know they're trying to make
it for so
how many did we say for curry that night
uh i think i said like something like 10
and i was
way off yes i
i think i went with four or four was the
right answer
yeah but a recap of what's happened thus
far
what would james harden rock to the
arena we said he got the hoodie
as juicy calls it the christmas carpet
uh
for number two the clipper the first
clipper out of the tunnel between kawhi
paul george luwil and serge ibaka
kawhi leonard was the first of those
four and now we are waiting on who dunks
first in the warm-ups kevin durant or
kawhi
and then will the final shot of the next
warm-up be a
make or a miss and while we wait to get
to those
we just put up here a new challenge off
the top of the dome
how many shots can kyrie irving make in
a minute
drewski said 25 i think i'm going with
four
um i did not say 20.
you ain't say 25 where did you get that
man
what's your number eight my number is
five okay i can't pick the same number
as you
yeah i mean you if you smart if you
smart you would
ski don't do a but you don't know he can
come out there don't do it i read kyrie
throw up four layups back to back to
back under the rim
don't don't don't do eight hey i see you
got that could have been records uh
hoodie on
yes i know you saw kyrie uh on instagram
live
uh like a month or two ago he was
rapping would you would you sign kyrita
could have been records
i would never wouldn't even give him a
shot
i think not near i think we got to make
that happen
no i think why why not i won't man
i ain't really rocking with him why not
what's wrong with uh what's wrong with
kyrie and his rapper see he more of like
a
because you gotta understand he's so
open with with life and you know
certain stuff he he i know he come in
lyrical i don't like none of them
super lyrical kendrick lamar cats man
but yeah y'all keep that i mean
it could have been no i i mean i hear
that you like the ignorant ain't nothing
wrong with the
ignorant you know atl style
let's see who duck kevin dude right off
the top is it it was a kd
was it to why did i miss it
kd out the gate
kd with the dunk can we pull up the
winners
can we pull up everybody who voted and
casted a pick
because i'm i'm dying to know i'm
excited to see winners okay so damn
i'm already disappointed because ak-96
is not up here which means he did not
make a prediction he won't be six
hundred dollars missed my boy man
ak-96 was yeah bruh
isaiah supreme though man
isaiah supreme is taking home 200 and
now
he may spend his 200 on some supreme i
don't
okay okay would you would would you
advise that or do you want him to go to
drewsky2funny.com
i think he'd be getting fake supreme if
he got it for 200
yeah that's some of my homies get it for
cheaper
yeah don't go to supreme
with that two hundred dollars man
he thought he was gonna go to exit or
whatever the website is called you get
it
aliexpress oh yeah express
[Laughter]
shout out to i can't read that name help
me
but he said they said five we got alan
saying 12 shots for kyrie i think 12 is
too many
i think 12 is too many sixes we got
somebody in here
they name it dad i don't like that i
don't like that
i don't like that i don't care how good
his number is i'm not feeling the name
dead
i don't want to see nobody here with the
name braden rusher with three
we'll see brady we'll see he said brady
great
hey drop some more comments some more
predictions on how many shots kyrie will
put up
we're still waiting on kyrie to come out
but set up all the way for the caveat
stock market ak-96
okay ak-96 the king of random pre-game
props
yeah hey ak-97 y'all see his name a lot
yup he going viral ak-96 you're welcome
the only place in the world where you
can go viral for predicting the most
random [ __ ] in a pre-game
it's the foreseer of cash
yeah ak nice man he undefeated
that's what i'm hearing that's what they
saying
listen though you had a very very busy
weekend i saw
you i think i know where you at right
now but i saw you in la
which is not where you're at right now
so what you were doing in l.a mr
hollywood
big time guy oh talk to him oh man
no i was in hollywood man you know i was
working i was on a set of uh
of course which is celebrity basketball
man
yeah of course listen to me hosting that
for season one to season two
currently i know the people at home was
wondering why i called you
my famous as co-host but this is why the
man is in hollywood
on his off days he's on sets
he has uh what do they call them he has
trailers he's we're doing rehearsal he's
he's telling the production crew he has
somewhere to be
you're the definite you're the
definition of hollywood man i'm proud
i know man you know and and i pray to
see you do the same in this upcoming
year man you you
i've definitely seen you before i even
met you i've seen you do some
great things already so keep going bro
hey no i appreciate that hey but listen
i'm getting worried that kyrie is taking
kyrie is taking a little too long so we
gonna remix
my in-game challenge instead of how many
shots kyrie can make in 60 seconds
james hard how many shots james harden
laid about do your challenge
yeah so that's what i was going to ask
is yo is your shot meter changed because
it's james harden now
talk to me y'all in the comments let me
know too we switching to james bond mine
definitely changes
i go with 12 now like like uh
the guy in the car i think that was uh i
forgot his name allen 24
if i'm not mistaken allen 24 16
i'm gonna go eight i'm gonna go eight
the clock is up
let's start the clock let's start the
clock how many shots james harden making
in 60
seconds i'm looking for james
look at him he just sat down
are you kidding me you just sat down
james
james get up get up james yo
this is why oh my god he's gonna piss me
off
this is gonna be one of the best things
ever because this is so unpredictable
nba pregame which is unpredictable here
we are
making an in-game challenge to see how
many shots
kyrie can hit he doesn't come out of the
tunnel we remix it to james harden
and right when we start the clock he
goes to take a seat what you got to say
to james harden drew
lazy man oh son of mine he up
he up he up at least give us one shot
yeah he's the only one
oh my god who picked one who picked one
three two one wow
are you kidding me are you freaking
kidding me
who in the comments yo who who in the
comments is a big one bruh
because you're right yes if somebody in
the comments said one please
find it for me that man deserves zero
that was close
that was very close matt with an
h m mahat sounded like somebody that's
hanging out with kyle roger kyle roger
yeah i'm a hat mad
mad dude mad we're totally coming over
tonight man
for sure dude matt you're super cool
like you're good with us
no you're chill you're chill you can
come by any time bro
for sure for sure for sure no i know
there go kyrie right there ate it they
got kyrie
shout out to my boy kyrie i think he was
watching can we get the kyrie countdown
now
let's get the kyrie count down that's
one drew you want the kyrie cat down
you want the caddy carrick now
are we getting the countdown for kyrie
yes we are let's do it let them know
when to start it
it's on you you make the call bro
started
uh i let him get into these running
rounds hold up
guys
here we go start it now start it now
start
pin pin is back
you off to a bad start you off to a bad
start if i wear this
man i want my i want my couch
tonight what number you looking at
i got five bro i got five you said 12.
oh man that was for james
oh then you said hey i'm sorry
we gonna get good at this though bro we
gonna get good at this
nba nba players are showing that they
have [ __ ]
they uh they're a little too nonchalant
for me man
he's up one there's one it's a little
it's a little too too cool you know
it's a little too cool out there for the
brooklyn nets
this your team though i last time i
talked to you say you're a broken net
fan
you jump ship to whoever the best team
you told me bandwagon
damn right damn right i respect it i
respect the honesty
so again in the in the 60 seconds we got
one for james and one for kyrie
and then he dunked it that's it
yo what's going on what is going on
tonight what is going on tonight
the nba is the most unpredictable
drop to his knees like yo what are you
doing man
so again another recap james harden rock
to the arena the hoodie
which clipper out of paul george kawhi
serge and lou will
we got kawhi who dunks first katie or
kawhi
kevin durant and then last but not least
drewski will the final shot of the next
warm-up be a make
or a miss now when we did rehearsal
the one that we was watching was a nail
biter that got us really at the edge of
our seats
i feel like this is gonna be different
because i think it's easily they usually
like to do like a layup or
uh or or or or done for the last one so
it's hard to say but sometimes
that last one might be a mess so i'll go
with miss this time
i'm i'm gonna go make i'm gonna go make
just because
it is the brooklyn nets they got kd
kyrie and hard
one of them has to take the left
somebody's gonna try to shoot a long
three though
you know you may be right
see i like the way you think man i like
the way you think i like that am i gonna
try to shoot a lot
i hope i'm saying that right shout out
to jay booth or whatever
um we got
raps overall with the miss i'm guessing
he's a raptor fan
shout out to raps overall um
kyrie is kyrie taking the last shot
brooklyn fan if the game is on the line
are you taking harden kyrie or durant
for the last shot talk to me
and i want to know why um
i gotta go damn i gotta go kd though man
i got a lot of faith in him
i've never i i've never been
disappointed by katie too too much
james harden i've been disappointed
sometimes kyrie's clutch as well
but i think k.d he gonna dag it
every time i gotta have to ask is this
is this a real pick or is that because
he was in the drake video with you
keep it real keep it a buck here we go
man
here we go hey last shot
let's see i think i i think the final
shots are coming down
we almost there james harden's at the
free throw line
he may get the last shot come on come on
let your last shot be hard
oh my gosh i told you somebody gonna
miss brooklyn that's man before they
walk in the
but you can't walk in on a mess i'm
seeing i'm seeing make after mate
i'm seeing make after me they had a
couple misses in there
i'm thinking james harden
but you may be right though somebody's
still out there dribbling about a
three-point line he may launch up that
three right before everybody lined up
gonna launch up that and that's gonna
miss it
oh right there right there is that it is
that it
missed it wasn't the best one
second three i want to know who that was
steve
after we announced these winners raps
are all
200 you're taking home i'm guessing
you're a raptor fan
raps overall congratulations to the rest
of the four
for the win let's see who was this that
they shot one three way out
it was way out over there by the
scoreboard look at that
is that jeff green is that jeff green
yeah
i don't i don't know who that is so i
don't want to say anything
but i told you i said somebody's going
to try to shoot it from real deep did i
not say that
you didn't say that that's why i said i
i like the way you think
i said i i deserve the 200 man
uh well according to the bank statements
that i've seen from you on google you
you you know
so unless y'all
james hard to rap to the arena with the
hoodie
kawhi leader was the first of four
clippers out of the tunnel
uh katie or kawhi with the dunk
kd got that one and then last but not
least with the final shot of the nets
one might be a make or a miss
like drewski called it it was a miss a
long three from almost half court and
then
which kind of upset me juicy
we doing this again next week bro
february 9th i can't rock it
i can't wait listen between
now and then don't do nothing to
hollywood bro
and i need my package of merch
oh you know you're getting mad you're
getting that 100 percent
hey gaston you might have it on next
time you hop on here
hey that's right my lover
hey final look at everything that
transpired in tonight's pre-game picks
episode james harden rocking the carpet
hoodie
as my twin said the x-men x-mas
carpet hoodie or whatever it's fly to me
though i like it
i like it look at the twins right here
though got
gotta push it down you gotta push it
that
guy should know it
peace always tune in bleacher report app
get those pre-game pics in for next week
drewski hey man you need to follow me
back too
your hollywood ass okay i see what we
doing here
i see what we doing here you're not
gonna extort me we out bro
you